- We're traveling to Kyiv
from Lviv where we've been
for the past two months.
(dramatic music)
It's still kind of dangerous to go back
but we really wanted to go back home
to check on our apartment, the parents,
so we're going back.
(dramatic music)
The roads to Kyiv have been perfect.
Like this specific highway
we're on, it is Kyiv-Chop,
which goes all the way to western Ukraine.
(dramatic music)
Traveling to Kyiv is about
seven to eight hours.
The biggest issue is getting gas.
So we are at a gas station right now.
Not a lot of them have any kind of gas.
A lot of them have limitations
in how much you can get into one car.
So we have to visit quite
a few of them on the way.
(dramatic music)
All the signs and all the guidance
and directions across the
roads have been removed.
Once the war started, we
have gotten information
and guidance from our
government in many ways,
and one of the ways
has been for the people
to remove the signs
and basically any names of cities
and villages that are on
the road as you travel.
So if and when Russian occupants make it
to this specific region,
it's very hard for them to orient,
even for us when we're
traveling back home,
we really have to go with the map
because there are no
pointers on where to travel.
And you really have to know
the road to get back home.
(dramatic music)
So we're in Kyiv region right now.
Probably around 10 to 15 miles from Kyiv.
There's a lot of destruction here,
a lot of residential homes,
a lot of infrastructure.
The bridge over the road,
this has been a way to cross the highway
has been entirely removed
by our governmental officials and the army
so the occupants' job would
be harder to get to places
and to settle here for
a longer period of time.
We saw multiple bridges like this.
Even though the cities around Kyiv
and the region and the villages
have taken a lot of heavy
fighting and destruction,
everything has been removed apart
from just a few pieces of
like tanks or machinery
just for people to see the
destroyed Russian vehicles.
(pensive music)
(camera clicking)
(voices murmuring)
(pensive music)